after months of waiting and speculation
at the full trailer for the eighth and
final season of Game of Thrones has
finally arrived ahead of the premiere on
April 14th from dragons at Winterfell
two significant glasses of wine here are
some small details you may have missed
Greyjoy family infighting took up a lot
of time in the seventh season good
things happened for Theon who reclaimed
his name after being tortured by Ramsay
Bolton
but Yara his formidable older sister was
captured and held hostage by conniving
uncle Johan hoping to provoke Theon
interet ally ating Euron currently holds
all the power in the situation with his
fleet having destroyed yara ships though
he seems to serve Cersei it's more
likely that he's simply looking out for
his own interests it's clear that at
least one Greyjoy ship is on the move in
the new trailer where a ship bearing the
Greyjoy's sigil is seen stuffed with an
entire army the leader of the ship is
sporting gold armor and slicked back
blond hair whoever it is it's the sure
sign that we haven't seen the last of
the Greyjoy family conflict in the final
moments of season 7 the night king used
his new ice dragon to demolish the wall
setting up an intense scenario for the
final season viewers were also concerned
about the fate of two characters who
were guarding the wall when it fell
tormund and beric Dondarrion it's a long
way down
crows keep telling me I'll get used to
it fun favorite tormund has been winning
over audiences for years two viewers
were devastated by the possibility of
his death but beric is known for
surviving almost anything through red
magic so it seemed possible that he
could still be alive
thankfully the trailer gave anxious fans
a glimpse of both torment and barek
flaming sword and all the most explosive
secret revealed during the sixth season
was that Jon Snow is not Ned Stark's
illegitimate son but actually Aegon
Targaryen rightful heir to the Iron
Throne
he's also the nephew to the nearest
Targaryen with whom he has recently
struck up a new problematic romance we
don't choose India currently the lovers
remain blissfully ignorant to their
family ties and the only characters with
any concrete knowledge of John's lineage
a bran stark and Sam Tali who haven't
got a chance to tell him yet the trailer
has a few shots hinting at when John and
Daenerys might find out about each other
there's a moment between the two in the
crypts of Winterfell where John's mother
Liana is buried as well as a moment with
the two of them approaching the Dragons
together which might mean John is taking
a ride on one this season John can also
be seen lingering in the godswood a
place that's been very important to the
stark family there's also a shot of
salmon bran looking furtively at someone
off screen which could be the moment
just before they break the news to John
about his new girlfriend the trailer
shows both of Daenerys is remaining
dragons arriving at Winterfell
stunning Sansa as she stands on the
ramparts fans already knew that the
dragons would return for the final
season as they will play an instrumental
part in the war against the White
Walkers
but bazarian Daenerys s third dragon who
fell during a battle with the night King
is conspicuously absent from the trailer
there's a lot of questions surrounding
vissarion's return like whether or not
Daenerys will be able to control him or
if he might return to his former self in
enemy hands he's a game changer and
leaving him out of the trailer feels
significance throughout Game of Thrones
Gendry has remained an enigma as one of
the only surviving Buster's of King
Robert Baratheon
he has been hunted and in hiding for
most of the series but though he has a
significant claim to the Iron Throne he
doesn't seem to want control of the
Seven Kingdoms as an apprentice
blacksmith he seems more concerned with
surviving than rolling
gendry's long absence was resolved in
season seven with
reveal that he's still working as a
blacksmith in the season 8 trailer he
seems to be forging swords which is
important in the lead-up to the final
battle with the White Walkers on the
move Westeros needs Valyrian steel
swords more than ever and Gendry may be
just the man for the job
audiences see two glimpses of Cersei
Lannister during the trailer and they
couldn't be more different
first she's standing triumphantly on the
shores of King's Landing flanked by the
sycophantic Coburn and her undead
bodyguard she looks completely in
control but in her next shots she's
alone in a quiet throne room holding a
glass of wine and seemingly on the verge
of tears last time we saw Cersei
clutching wine on the Iron Throne
it was drawing season two's Blackwater
when she thought the city was about to
fall so to mimic that moment seem
significant also last season saw her
shock her family by revealing that she
was pregnant with Jamie's baby after the
reveal as she began to conspicuously
decline alcohol so we have to wonder
what happens to make Cersei pick up the
bottle again one of the longest-running
couples of the entire show came to an
apparent end during the seventh season
when Jaime Lannister left his sister
behind to help protect Westeros he's
disgusted that Cersei would choose to
stay out of the fight against the White
Walkers so he leaves King's Landing
apparently heading to Winterfell to join
his brother Tyrion against Circe's
wishes even though there's still time
for Jamie to return to his sister side
he seems to be sticking to his guns and
the trailer but there was not revealed
where he is
fans can guess that he may have arrived
at Winterfell as he tells an unseen
character that he promised to fight for
the living not just the Lannisters
since Jamie is seen elsewhere in the
trailer bloodied and fighting at a
castle that maybe Winterfell it seems
like he may just turn against Cersei
after all throughout the trailer
glimpses of battles pop up here and
there but thanks to plenty of fire and
smoke it's still unconfirmed where those
particular scenes take place however in
the final shot of the trailer viewers
clearly see Daenerys as army of
unsullied alongside Brienne of Tarth her
loyal Squire Podrick Payne and an
heiress his closest advisor Jorah
Mormont waiting in front of Winterfell
is a ghostly horse's legs quietly take a
step towards them indicating the fate of
Westeros may come down to a massive
battle at Winterfell
where the series introduced us to its
world years ago we hope they've got
enough for Larry and Steele we know
Brienne has a Valyrian sword but the
rest of the army could be woefully
underprepared hope somebody brought the
Dragons check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]